Aanswer to our quiz--we can find this out by running delta debugging.
Here we are again in our editor, and now we simply invoke ddmin on the HTML input
to find out which part of the input actually causes the program to fail.
You press on run and here we go.
It takes 10 tests until delta debugging has simplified the input just to two characters
and this is a quote and a less than sign.
These two characters already sufficed to trigger the failure.
This simplified input dramatically reduces the number of steps it takes us
to go through the remove HTML model fashion.
We have a quote--if a quote becomes set, this is the error.
Since quote is set, tag does not become true and the quote gets added to the result,
which causes the assertion to fail.
Just two characters, fewer steps, smallest state--all of these are advantages of a simplified input.
And just for the record, the correct answer is double quote and less than sign.